what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are starting Marvel's new Spider-Man
Centric event which is called Dark web
and honestly it's really more of like a
Spider-Man X-Men crossover that also
Associates with Venom as the story
unfolds we'll figure out more who is all
involved in this but while we will be
covering the story we also kind of have
to explain things along the way and the
first thing we're going to do here is
we're going to talk about Ben Reilly so
Ben Reilly leading up to the story you
actually had Amazing Spider-Man the big
takeaway from all of this is that Ben
Reilly had seemingly just reappeared in
Peter Parker's life and this made sense
right because Ben Reilly really became a
major character back in the day in
Marvel Comics as part of the original
clone saga and then the reworked clone
saga in the 1990s that he was
effectively a clone of Peter Parker that
was created when Marvel was trying to
replace Peter or Spider-Man and
introduce somebody else and it was a
great big huge nightmare but Ben Reilly
is just kind of disappeared and
reappeared from all the comics over the
years sometimes his reappearances are
important sometimes they're not during
the more recent Arc what we ended up
finding out is that following the
collapse of Parker industries that a
company called Beyond Corporation ended
up buying all the different assets that
belong to Parker Industries one of which
was the name and likeness of Spider-Man
which had been copyrighted by Peter
Parker or at least copyrighted by Parker
Industries in order to ensure that there
couldn't be anybody out there operating
as Spider-Man in addition to Peter but
because Peter never solidified the
copyrights for himself meaning he never
took them or brought them under his own
name from Parker Industries when Beyond
Corporation bought Parker Industries
they got the rights along with it and so
what they did is they basically had Ben
Riley become the new Spider-Man and
literally issued a cease and desist to
Peter Parker now some of the things that
were also going on behind the scenes is
we saw the return of Janine Janine was a
character who Rose to prominence in the
1990s in Marvel Comics as what was
basically supposed to be Ben Reilly's
version of Mary Jane Watson didn't
really last too long and by the
mid-1990s Marvel had basically written
her out when she had come back here it
was after serving a prison sentence for
having previously murdered her dad and
of course was brought in to kind of be
Ben Reilly's love interest and the the
person that would sort of keep him on
the moral track such as it was given her
own background
but the other part of this is that Ben
Reilly operating under Beyond
Corporation the relationship between the
two was really almost identical to the
relationship between Hydra and uh and
Bucky Barnes from like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in the sense that
Beyond Corporation was basically
bankrolling Ben Reilly's efforts that
they were financing everything he did
they gave him the suit the whole nine
yards but what they would do is they
would selectively remove memories from
Ben Reilly's own mind in order to keep
him under their control eventually Ben
Riley learned about everything Beyond
corporations scrubbed the whole project
and then just disappeared and so what
Ben Riley had been doing leading up to
this Amazing Spider-Man number 13 story
is he had actually been going after
these different safe houses that belong
to Beyond Corporation in order to take
pot shots at the company which was now
operating underground but also to secure
different pieces of equipment for his
own goal and the reason for that is
because Ben Riley has had this kind of
lingering feeling in his mind that he's
being tugged somewhere he doesn't
entirely know what that place is but he
knows that constructing a portal is
necessary in order for him to get there
and so what takes place here is that
Janine actually ends up traveling to
Grand Central to kind of regain her
bearings because she's not entirely sure
how she feels about Ben Reilly
constructing a portal that just sort of
leads to somewhere no idea where it's
going to take him right maybe take him
to the realm of the cinebites but as
she's there she ends up meeting with the
guy who runs the restaurant and the two
of them are just kind of casually
talking of course he knows her identity
as Janine Godby he recognizes her
because of course Beyond Corporation
have kind of dumped the information out
into the world but one of the things
that happens is a waitress comes up to
the chef and tells him that the
dishwasher is on their way there he's
just running a little bit late and
that's when she realizes this is a very
very poorly concocted effort by the
waitress to alert this guy that the cops
are on their way Janine picks up on it
pretty fast literally stabs the guy in
the hand with a fork and then flees for
her life and when that happens she gets
back gets back to Ben Riley and
basically joins his cause now the reason
why this matters and it's it's really an
attempt to sort of build up the
character of Janine back in the 1990s
when she was introduced and we learned
her backstory that she was abused by her
dad and ended up killing him because of
his actions this is how her and Ben
Reilly bonded that Ben Riley was in a
lot of ways a cast off the fact that
they both felt like they had no place in
the world is what unified them and
brought them together and that
ultimately led to Ben Reilly and Janine
forming a romantic interest and then
again becoming a kind of Peter Parker
Mary Jane Watson type situation now of
course when everything was wrapped up
and her character came to an end and
disappeared as she's reappearing here
it's reinvigorating that idea that
there's no place for her in the world
because during her time when she had or
really when Ben Riley was operating a
Spider-Man and she was his love interest
it was the closest the two of them had
ever gotten to living that Peter Parker
Mary Jane Watson fantasy life because it
was the life they always wanted for
themselves but once that was stripped
away from them they were sort of cast
back down so to speak to the life they
were trying to escape from and now
they're kind of forging their own path
with Janine saying you Ben Riley feel
like there's no place for you in the
world your memories and your identities
have basically been stripped from your
you I lost my life when I was thrown in
prison and that kind of thing so let's
just live that life together of course
she agrees to Aid him in his efforts and
that's when he re-dawns the costume of
Chasm now that's the other part of what
was going on with Ben Reilly that during
the original Spider-Man story or really
during the more recent Spider-Man story
that in the first encounter of the first
outing when Ben Riley went out and did
his thing he faced off against the UFOs
Peter Parker intervened Peter Parker
ultimately succumbed to the effects of
their abilities which was essentially
radiation sickness now this led to like
Aunt May hitting up Dr Octopus because
at one time they were going to get
married in the comics they've had a
lengthy not really relationship but
they're aware of each other that she
ended up hitting him up that he
basically helped to cure Peter learned
what was going on with the Beyond
Corporation and Ben Reilly and
threatened to expose all their actions
and there's a whole bunch of other stuff
that goes into it that is not overly
important in relation to this the long
and short is at the end of the story
basically saw Peter Parker fighting Ben
Reilly and then Ben Riley was believed
to have been dead he was ultimately
discovered by Janine but because so much
of his life had been taken away meaning
that he couldn't be Spider-Man anymore
right a lot of his memories were gone he
started calling himself Chasm because
that's basically how he felt on the
inside it's sort of an on the nose name
but it works for what it is but with
Chasm and Janine or really been Riley
engineering going forward and doing
their own thing they're ultimately able
to construct this portal and when the
portal is opened and Ben Reilly passes
through Ben Reilly passes into limbo
where he meets Madeleine Pryor now
here's the thing we need to explain this
because I feel like a lot of people who
are picking up Marvel Comics recently
are not overly familiar with Madeleine
Pryor unless you've been reading New
Mutants recently or unless you've been
reading the X-Men Madeline Pryor is a
character that is unfamiliar to you so
let's wind the clock back in Marvel
Comics to like the 1970s
let's go all the way back to the 1970s
right let's go to the aftermath of the
dark Phoenix Saga when Jean Gray dies
there's a villain in Marvel Comics named
Mr Sinister who most all of you are
aware of and Mr Sinister had realized
that if Jean Gray and cyclops ever had a
child together their child would be
Godly powerful the problem is he
couldn't really abscond with Jean Gray
and then force her to initiate a
coupling with Cyclops because they would
resist plus you know it's a pretty dark
level of Storytelling concerning what
Marvel was doing at the time and so what
ended up happening here is that in an
effort to produce a child between
Cyclops and Gene which was really more
based on their their actual genealogy as
opposed to their powers he cloned Jean
Gray and that's where you got Madeline
Pryor now Madeleine Pryor showed up to
basically meet with Cyclops when he was
in Anchorage Alaska just kind of living
his own life and leaving the X-Men after
Jean Gray died and where the story
depicted itself as Cyclops sort of
knowing that it wasn't really Jean he
leaned into the idea that it could be
Gene and so really just kind of lied to
himself right he just tricked himself
and ultimately he and uh and Madeline
ended up having a child named Nathan
Summers who by a different set of events
was whisked off to the Future and
ultimately became cable but literally
when Cyclops learns that Jean Gray's
alive that she effectively returned
after her supposed death which we're not
going to get into the house get into how
that happened Cyclops basically bailed
on Madeleine Pryor he literally
abandoned his wife and went back to Gene
it was kind of a big to do in Marvel
Comics at the time like damn like a
superhero just abandoning his wife and
his child like that's kind of a dick
move Chris Claremont and of course that
initiated the launch of The X Factor
comics in Marvel but the thing about
this is Madeleine Pryor had always held
on to that Grudge because she saw
herself much in the same way that Ben
Reilly saw himself as becoming Peter and
Janine saw herself as becoming Mary Jane
that Madeleine always saw herself as the
rightful love interest of Cyclops and
always pursued the life that Jean Gray
wanted this led into a great big huge
story called uh Inferno where literally
Madeleine Pryor makes a deal with demons
and invades the city of New York it was
a cool story but Madeleine Pryor of
course has basically we've been dead and
Marvel Comics who have been dead in
Marvel Comics for a little while until
Jonathan Hickman launched his X-Men run
Madeleine Pryor was one of the mutants
who was brought back but the rules in
krakowa is you can't have a clone of an
existing member of krakowa in the mutant
island of krakowa itself and so where
this led to the rejection of the fact
that Madeleine Pryor could be brought
back after her death what ended up
happening is she was secretly returned
but because the rules of kakawa say
mutants cannot kill mutants and they
cannot kill humans that everybody there
was kind of forced to give Madeline
Pryor her own domain removed from being
a threat to anybody else so she was
literally Cast Away back to the realm of
limbo where she's been residing ever
since and that's why when Ben Reilly
passes through here Madeleine Pryor is
there waiting for him and it's a really
interesting thing because Madeline Pryor
she's had significant roles in Marvel
Comics it wasn't even just Inferno right
like she manipulated the original X-Men
Nate gray right the age of Age of
Apocalypse version of cable everything
the cable could become if he didn't have
the technology organic virus bonded to
his body and constantly had to keep the
virus from eating him alive X-Man nay
gray was stupidly overpowered this guy
was next level in terms of his
capabilities but what's important here
is that with the two of them meeting the
reality is they find common ground and
the reason why and it's a little
ambiguous here that Madeleine Pryor says
that limbo always tugs to people who
feel cast out in some capacity now that
kind of ties into like the old school
magic stories right with Ileana Rasputin
which really dealt with the introduction
of like the Demonic limbo in Marvel for
the first time the idea that she was
locked away there and then basically
learned how to use powers while she was
there but the reality here is Madeleine
Pryor kind of hitting at this idea that
the realm of limbo always tugs to those
who feel cast out who feel like they
have no place that's the reason why Ben
Reilly felt the desire to come here it's
the reason why he was sort of pulled in
this direction and so what ends up
happening is Ben Riley and Madeleine
Pryor actually end up making an
agreement with each other they end up
making a deal with each other that Ben
Riley wants the life that he feels
belongs to him the life of Peter Parker
and the memories of Peter Parker all of
which have been taken from him though
those were memories that he had when he
was cloned initially and believed that
he was the actual Peter Parker that was
the entire foundation and the basis
behind the original clone saga but
Madeleine Pryor also feels like the life
that Jean Gray has is the life that she
should have so both of them are really
pursuing the lives of different people
who live on earth and so what you end up
having is this conversation that takes
place between Ben Reilly and Janine and
Madeleine Pryor when Ben Reilly brings
Janine to the realm of Limbaugh Janine
feels a little off about it all but she
feels a little strange about it all like
I mean I kind of get where you guys are
coming from but I feel a little weird
about the fact that my man has whisked
off to a demonic realm and is kind of
finding common ground with like this
red-haired chick that looks like
Kerrigan from Starcraft but like she
feels a little weird about it but the
funny thing is that Madeleine Pryor
meets directly with Janine and it kind
of has this conversation and saying
you're not that dissimilar from us like
she literally says like me you despise
it being at the mercy of forces beyond
your control you would rather shape your
own destiny than play the Perpetual
victim and so what ends up happening is
Madeleine Pryor presents her with
basically an object an artifact and says
if you choose to accept this then you
can literally reshape your destiny you
can make your life what you want it to
be because it will grant you power and
so initially she rejects it but then
agrees that she's tired of sitting on
the sidelines and watching like Ben
Reilly do stuff she's tired of sitting
on the sidelines and feeling like she's
in the passenger seat of her own life
and so this artifact is literally placed
into Janine and when that happens
Madeline sees control lover casts a
spell and then turns her into somebody
who has probably one of the most
ridiculous names ever which is called
hollow's Eve I don't mean to be like a
like to beat down
the overall story is cool but come on
man like can we not think of better
names than hollow's Eve come up with a
better name it's just too on the nose
and so in an effort to basically
demonstrate to Ben Riley that the words
of Madeleine Pryor are true and she can
actually give him what it is that he
wants what she does is she sends him
back to Earth in order to gather or to
grab a person that can allow her to cast
a spell to demonstrate what she's
capable of and so Ben Riley travels back
to the city of New York and ends up
meeting with a guy named Gus now Gus had
previously hounded Ben Riley believing
Ben was Peter Parker over debts that
were owed by Peter and so when Ben
Reilly gets back here he kind of allows
Gus to play the game a little bit and
saying like I know you're Peter I've
talked to everybody that you know and
like you owe us money Peter like you
need to pay up and we're gonna go after
people and so on and so forth but trying
to strong-arm Ben Riley and so much to
the enjoyment of anybody who has
encountered a debt collector Ben Reilly
whisked this guy off to a demonic realm
literally overcomes this guy he's like
you know what debt collector we're gonna
do what everybody wants to do to you
which is take you to hell and so this
literally leads to this debt collector
being brought to Madeleine Pryor this
guy's terrified out of his mind but she
feeds him from a tree this is called the
tree of Exquisite knowledge it
immediately kills him but it's not him
dying that's important here what is
important is that by consuming the fruit
what it does is it allows Madeleine
Pryor to extract this guy's soul from
his body and when that happens it allows
her to know everything he knew and
that's when she's actually like I mean
okay where's the guy a debt collector
yeah and should Peter Parker have paid
his debts sure other guy otherwise this
guy wouldn't have been hounding him but
in reality he was a terrible person and
did some incredibly terrible things and
in fact he was basically a serial killer
and so the result of this is it
demonstrates to Ben Riley if we can get
Peter Parker to consume part of this
tree we can basically extract the soul
from his body you consume it and you
replace Peter Parker for her it's the
same thing she could extract the soul of
Jean Gray and know everything that Jean
Gray knows and literally take over her
life and so that's literally the
campaign of the two of them going
forward now truth to tell I'm not
current with dark web I haven't read any
of the stories that are going on with it
yet I don't know if it's cool or I don't
know if it's trash we'll find out
because we're gonna cover it but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace